when wales line up against ukraine
support in this household will be split
maria and her son robert have been
getting used to life in cardiff
they left ukraine six weeks ago to live
with sarah and her family in wales but
the mutual support they share will be
tested for 90 minutes maria will be at
the match cheering ukraine
so emotions so
very big i think i will be happy and i
believe ukrainian team
will be win
uh one month said
in sunday we are not friend but in
monday we will be front again
for wales though the stakes are high the
players preparing to fight for a place
in the world cup for the first time in
over 60 years
but to get there they'll need to beat
aside who'll have support from around
the world if we could take away what
they're going through in a heartbeat we
absolutely would every single one of the
staff and players
now this is business and that's it it's
not spoken about in camp
this is an opportunity for wales for us
to qualify to a for a world cup and and
full focus is on that
at this pub in cardiff memories from
euro 2016 the last time wales came close
in a major tournament
tributes to their star player as the
nation hopes gareth bale and the team
can do it again
but eight-year-old james and his dad are
nervous
i'm feeling a little bit
scared about ukraine beating us not in
my lifetime we've been in the world cup
so i think um obviously after the euros
and the excitement of what wales
football have done yeah fingers crossed
if the result doesn't go our way i don't
think anybody over graduate ukraine
would go into the world cup finals in
you know in the current situation which
is
absolutely tragic
the ukraine side are fresh from victory
in scotland they came out fighting
midweek for their first game since their
country was invaded
team and manager determined to give
their country something to celebrate
for both teams it'll be emotional as
they kick off here in cardiff wales are
used to being the popular underdogs in
big matches but this time they'll feel
the support of the world against them as
they try to do what no welsh team has
achieved for more than six decades
a win would mean the world to welsh fans
but who would want to bet against
ukraine in this game of survival becky
johnson sky news cardiff